on this Tuesday night America's
escalating coronavirus crisis
overwhelmed hospitals rising infections
and rising deaths and people will be
needlessly died plus how much longer the
canada-us border could stay closed to
non-essential travel a Quebec father
still on the run the obstacles making
this manhunt even tougher saving
Atlantic right whales Canada's efforts
to preserve and protect this endangered
species and he spent months in intensive
care it is a miracle that he survived in
one man's cautionary tale about kovat 19
was my second chance
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the quest for a
corona virus vaccine human clinical
trials are now underway here in Canada
of a vaccine can of a developed by a
Canadian company part of the race for a
vaccine that's taking place in labs
around the world
Quebec biopharmaceutical company
medicago began the first of three phases
of clinical trials yesterday the company
says 180 healthy volunteers between the
ages of 18 and 55 are taking part it
hopes to move to phase 2 and 3 by
October that will involve testing a
wider field of volunteers today Canada's
deputy public health officer cautioned
that early evidence just even those who
have had coated 19 may not be immune to
it for long you could get it a game the
same way people keep catching colds
that's why a vaccine is vital most
scientists are being very optimistic
might think that if it were if there
were to be a vaccine it really wouldn't
be before 2021 what I think also
important is that we do these trials
properly never before has so much effort
been concentrated on vaccine development
23 potential candidates have now reached
human clinical trials two frontrunners
have moved into Phase three and
widespread human testing in May the
National Research Council of Canada said
it was collaborating with the Chinese
firm Cansino on another potential
vaccine human trials in Canada of that
are delayed though they have begun on
Chinese military personnel in the
absence of a vaccine the only effective
way to break the chain of transmission
is by keeping people physically distant
the u.s. is a grim case study and what
happens when you reopen the economy too
soon it now has nearly 3.4 million
confirmed cases of COBIT 19 and more
than a hundred and thirty six thousand
people are known to have died from it
and today at least three states North
Carolina Alabama and Florida reported a
record number of deaths in a single day
the worst may still be yet to come the
director of the Centers for Disease
Control says he fears fall and winter
will be as he says one of the most
difficult times that Americans
have experienced in public health
Jackson prosecco reports on the kovat 19
crisis still out of control on the front
lines of the pandemic doctors across the
u.s. are seeing something tragically
predictable record numbers of
hospitalizations and deaths
if one place in the United States is
unsafe then we're all unsafe from cover
19 dr. VIN Gupta is a lung specialist in
Seattle he says while kovat 19
treatments have improved a wave of new
fatalities is now unavoidable after the
rapid rise in cases in so many states at
some point this increase in cases is
going to result in an overwhelming
amount of hospitalizations that will
spill over into ICUs and people will
needlessly die there's only so much the
system can take and we know that even if
you're young you can end up in the ICU
at the same time testing shortages have
come roaring back the system is so
overwhelmed with demand it's taking more
than a week for many Americans to get
their results yes testing delays are
running a week plus you're gonna miss
the window for possibly as many as two
different two more generations of
transmission before you get even the
test results on that first generation
that means the virus is spreading
undetected in New York there are fears
of a resurgence in cases the governor
has expanded a mandatory quarantine
order to cover anyone coming from 22
different states we can't be in a
situation where we have people coming
from other states in the country
bringing the virus more and more states
are eyeing a fresh shutdown as the only
way to get the pandemic under control
they may reluctantly end indoor dining
and closed bars and gyms all over again
but even if they do it tomorrow it will
be too late to stop this surge and
tonight there are concerns about how
that surge will be documented and
monitored the Trump administration is
now ordering hospitals to bypass the
Centers for Disease Control and send key
information about hospital bed use and
ventilator usage directly to a national
database being kept in Washington Donna
that is raising serious concerns about
the data being politicized or even
manipulated to downplay the severity of
the crisis
Jaxson Prosecco in Washington Thanks
there are reports the US and Canada have
agreed to keep the border closed for at
least another month the border will stay
shut to non-essential travel until at
least August 21st the border has been
closed since March 21st and its
reopening has now been pushed back four
times only essential workers trade
shipments and those reuniting with
immediate family members are allowed to
cross recent polling suggests more than
80 percent of Canadians favor keeping
the border restrictions in place and
Canada's public health officers agree
Canadians have made tremendous
sacrifices to date and in terms of
flattening the curve and we are we're
seeing the fruits of our Labor's to be
quite honest and I think we're very
mindful that we don't want to quote
waste those efforts by a potentially
quote reintroducing the virus into
Canada and increasing the risk of
further transmissions a couple from
Florida has been charged after failing
to self isolate for 14 days after
arriving in Northern Ontario from the
United States
police say the couple arrived through
the Fort Erie border crossing on July
3rd on route to a seasonal property
after failing a compliance check they
were charged under the quarantine act
and both were fined $1,000 they're now
being closely monitored by the local
health unit on the weekend Florida
shattered the US record for the largest
single-day increase in new cases of
kovat 19 in any American state in other
news the intense manhunt for a Quebec
father of two young girls who were found
dead is now in its sixth day police have
expanded the search for Martin carpenter
who was last seen on Wednesday with his
two daughters when they were still alive
the focus of the search is dense
forested terrain near Quebec City as
Mike Armstrong reports people who live
nearby are on edge it is a massive
effort
searchers on the ground checking every
inch of ditches while in the air the
land is being scanned by thermal cameras
police had cordoned off and focused the
search on one specific area about 15
square kilometers they've now expand
that to about fifty square kilometers
watching it all people in the area
getting more and more nervous see kick
Scholes he he was late yep
this woman says it's scary that her
family doesn't go out like they normally
would
forty four-year-old math take apart she
has now been missing for six days he
abducted his daughter's last Wednesday
Noah and homie were found dead in the
forest three days later the girl's
mother spoke out Monday calling them her
princesses of love Emily Lemieux said
her daughters were her reason for living
know that pain is shared by Knutson
Billy oh she's lived through it in 2012
her ex killed her two children missile
approaching man but also she's been
taken right back into the pain she lived
and can't stop thinking about the Meuse
suffering what may make it all worse is
that gap party is still missing we don't
know what he has survival expert Sheldon
Kong's as it's possible kept on C is
moving constantly that makes a search
harder he may also have gotten outside
the perimeter where police are looking
it's possible that he can travel farther
than people may expect one think a party
has going for him is stress conks is the
psychological motivation of trying to
evade police can help someone push their
body harder than they normally be able
to Mike Armstrong global news Montreal a
day after Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
apologized for another controversy that
is all his own making we're waiting to
see what happens next
Trudeau's wife mother and brother have
been paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars to appear at we charity events
Trudeau now says he should have recused
himself from discussions about whether
to award the charity the deal to
administer a nine hundred million dollar
federal student grant contract the
opposition Tories want the RCMP to
investigate the ethics commissioner is
investigating terno has broken ethics
rules twice before in this case raises
more questions about his judgment today
our Abigail Beeman spoke with the
previous ethics commissioner Abigail
what does she have to say Donna Mary
Dawson
wants to be careful not to step on the
current Ethics Commissioners toes so
she's not offering up predictions but
she does say while the Prime Minister's
interview with the current commissioner
is what matters most
his public apology this week makes a
difference
it's the admission that he feels that he
has not failed to recuse which is the
requirement of the act so he's
effectively said I've not followed the
act as far as I can see so it seems to
me that's one probably fairly certain
finding of contravention does that make
the ethics commissioners job easier if
the subject comes right out and says I
apologize oh yeah oh yeah Dawson says
she produced about 30 reports in her 10
years on the job her Trudeau
investigation took about a year and she
says her findings there show the Act
applies to the prime minister as equally
as to anyone else it was like any other
case and I think one had to be very
careful it's people's reputations and so
one had to look into it carefully and
make sure you you've had the proper
facts maybe people don't understand it's
actually carried out much like a
judicial process and a note on language
there were previously debates over how
to phrase it when Trudeau was found to
have broken the ethics rules twice
before Dawson says you never use the
word guilty that refers to criminal law
this is about contraventions under civil
law Donna
Abigail Beeman and Ottawa thank you now
to a global news investigation about
RCMP surveillance of some First Nations
groups three years ago a watchdog report
investigated complaints officers
inappropriately spied on some indigenous
people opposed to a pipeline yet the
RCMP has failed to provide a response as
Heather Eurex West explains the delay is
raising serious questions about whether
the RCMP watchdog can effectively hold
Canada's national police force to
account in 2010 a group of northern BC
First Nations began a campaign to stop
the northern gateway pipeline from being
built across their territory they had no
idea they were being watched by the RCMP
until a 2011 intelligence report came to
light
in it the RCMP described a private
meeting organized by the indigenous
leaders I was in shock I didn't expect
that of the RCMP and February 2014 the
BC celebrities Association filed a
complaint with the RCMP civilian review
commission the CRC which acts as a
watchdog to the RCMP agreed to
investigate in June 2017 a report was
submitted to the RCMP but to date there
has been no response from the
commissioner and the report has not been
made public this copy obtained through
access to information legislation is
heavily redacted but in a letter to the
BC Civil Liberties Association the
Commission's acting director revealed
the report contained 18 findings and
seven recommendations for the force we
believe that it seems that the civilian
review commission may have found
evidence that the RCMP was in fact
engaged in those activities and here we
are six years later and we can't even
get confirmation about vetting this
criminology professor says the delay
speaks to a big problem with how the
civilian review commission is able to
hold the RCMP to account it is a
toothless Bulldog whose role in reality
is to give a vania of legality to a
fundamentally flawed process the RCMP
says due to the volume and complexity of
the relevant material it's still
difficult to predict how much longer it
will take to respond to the watchdog's
report but it hopes to put forward a
response by the fall of this year after
three years Jacquie Thomas believes
enough time has already passed I would
like to see it public I would like to
read it and and review it for myself
whether your exbest Global News Calgary
charged with luring young girls coming
up the former girlfriend or Jeffrey
Epstein enters a plea in her Sex Crimes
case
in a New York courtroom ghilane Maxwell
pleaded not guilty today to charges she
facilitated the sex abuse of underage
girls by her late ex-boyfriend Jeffrey
Epstein Maxwell appeared by a video link
in Manhattan she's accused of luring at
least three girls in the 1990s including
one as young as 14 and grooming them to
endure sexual abuse by Epstein actually
was denied bail after two accusers
begged the judge to keep her in
detention she'll stay behind bars until
her trial next July if convicted Maxwell
faces up to 35 years in jail the UK has
reversed its decision on wall way saying
today that Chinese telecom giant will be
banned from its 5g networks by the end
of this year Britain's mobile networks
must stop buying Huawei equipment and
within seven years they'll need to
remove the company's existing components
from their infrastructure Britain's
leading Intelligence Agency says it
could no longer guarantee the supply of
Huawei equipment after US sanctions were
imposed on the company the move is
expected to delay the rollout of the
UK's 5g network by up to three years
Canada is now the last of the five eyes
countries to make a decision on using
Huawei's 5g technology today the federal
government said it's still considering
advice from our security agencies and
from our allies and partners one step
from extinction ahead the new warning
about right whales
the future of the North Atlantic right
whale is deeply uncertain today the
International Union for Conservation of
Nature classified this species as
critically endangered that's just one
step away from becoming extinct right
whales have been on the endangered list
in Canada for some time and as Jesse
Thomas reports as hope the international
attention will make a difference before
it's too late
2019 was devastating for the North
Atlantic right whale nine whales died
their giant gray carcasses found
floating in the waters around the Gulf
of st. Lawrence and the eastern waters
off Nova Scotia we know why they died
for the most part we know they get hit
by vessels and they get caught in
fishing gear we know why they're injured
it's the same two things
Tonya Wimmer collaborated on the 2019
Atlantic right whale incident report 210
pages detailing the dire circumstances
for a species on the brink of extinction
experts believe the population hovers
around 400 migrating along the east
coast of North America from Florida to
the Gulf of st. Lawrence the majority of
deaths over the past four years have
been in Canadian waters 12 whales died
in and around the Gulf of st. Lawrence
in 2017 these are animals that used to
number in the tens of thousands last
week the International Union for
Conservation of Nature classified the
Ray whale as critically endangered
estimating fewer than 250 mature whales
are alive today Fisheries and Oceans
Canada says no deaths or entanglements
have been reported in Canadian waters so
far this season but off the coast of New
Jersey last month a young right whale
died after being hit by a ship Fisheries
and Oceans Canada confirmed there have
been fewer vessels like cruise ships in
Canadian waters but fishing activities
and the Gulf of st. Lawrence have been
on par with previous seasons identifying
critical habitats with use of acoustic
technology and aerial surveillance by
plane along with innovations and
modification to fishing gear have all
been credited with keeping the
population safer this season in British
Columbia a study examining noise levels
in the Strait of Georgia found noise
levels in the water in April were five
decibels quieter than the previous year
that's a 50% drop in
noise pollution says this oceanographer
and we found in the inshore waters just
out to the Port of Vancouver that the
mean weekly power had decreased by about
half over that first quarter so over
those first three months and offshore
out in the deep deep ocean it had
reduced by about 15% and wimmer hopes
international acknowledgement of the
right whales endangered status helps
coordinate protection efforts all this
international attention all of these
other international experts who might
now sort of look at the issue and say
how can I help and help bring this
endangered species back from the brink
of extinction
Jessie Thomas Global News Halifax next
the Toronto man who spent nine weeks on
a ventilator finally breathe fresh air
there is so much doctors still don't
know about Wieck Ovid 19 hits some
people so hard and why others have no
symptoms every patient offers new
insight in Toronto one fifty one year
old man was so sick he spent nine weeks
on a ventilator doctors knew his odds
were not good and yet somehow he came
through it
Karen Lieberman has his story Mario
Castillo enjoys his first real breaths
of fresh outdoor air in four months the
last time he saw the Sun it was March is
my feast is go upside to feel something
simple doctors never imagined would be
possible for someone who fell so sick
with kovat 19 maybe I don't will a club
I feel of my boys oh you know I'm not
feeling good the 51 year old mechanic
spent the next week in bed before
finally going to the ER the doctor
coming in said to me oh you love me you
have the COBE so he presented to the
hospital about five to ten days after
symptoms started with shortness of
breath dr. Jaime Spiegelman treated
Castillo in the ICU initially he only
required oxygen but within hours his
respiratory status worsened he became
Humber River hospital's first intubated
kovat positive patient wouldn't with him
the machine as a wooden everything
though the efforts of the medical team
were relentless but his condition
continued to deteriorate we didn't think
he was going to survive because he was
on so much life-support doctors don't
know why some patients died from the
virus while others survived no one
really understands the pathology behind
it yet Castillo's wife also tested
positive for the virus from the family
home in quarantine
she kept hoping he would pull through we
just keep praying
I know Mario can make it he's a fighter
he's a strong man for three excruciating
months she was not allowed to visit her
husband what if something happened to
him I didn't even say I love you
I didn't even hug him Castillo's x-ray
shows significant damage to the lungs
but within weeks his condition began to
improve after 70 days on a ventilator I
opened my eyes and I see everybody but
they'll put on me
for survivors of kovat 19 beating it may
just be the beginning the virus has
taken a toll on Castillo's body this is
my goal to walk and to but earlier my
work can do it they said me do it before
he still has a long road to go to get
back to his baseline the fact is he
survived it and it is a miracle that
he's arrived into this point and
Castillo does not take that for granted
there's my Ficklin John Karen Lieberman
Global News Toronto and that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm donor
Friesen tonight share of Canada is C
cones ice cream boat in hulls harbour
Nova Scotia it's an authentic FET
fishing vessel transformed into an ice
cream parlor it's closed right now
because of the pandemic but they hope to
welcome ice cream lovers back next year
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]